container nodes in gdau gives us out of
the box functionalities that helps us
determinate how things should be
arranged we have three types of nodes in
gdo the blue ones which have to do with
CHD gameplay the red ones which have to
do with the 3D environment of your game
and we have the green nodes which are
control nodes used to create UI for your
games the container nodes can take
control of said control nodes and also
rearrange them not only buttons labels
textures but they also can rearrange and
take control of other containers this
whole scene right here was created using
only three types of containers the
horizontal and vertical box containers
as well as margin containers before we
dive into this scene we're first going
to take a look at this demo right here
as you can see the root node of our
scene is a vertical box container a
vertical box container works pretty much
like a list it's going to order the
children on the same order that it has
them on the inspector so as you can see
here in the scry we have two direct
children of this vertical box container
which are two horizontal box containers
the horizontal box containers work as
the opposite of the vertical box
container so they're going to arrange
their children in a horizontal manner
you can see that we have four buttons
and again this is just for demo purposes
so so if I decide to add another
horizontal box container here so I'm
going to select this one and press
contrl D to duplicate you notice that it
everything gets rearranged by our
vertical box container and the same is
going to happen if I decide to duplicate
one of the buttons right here everything
gets rearranged accordingly and again if
I decide to hide this button they get
rearranged again these two containers
are the main ones that you're going to
use throughout your game with then you
can create pretty much any type of UI
and it's a really good practice in go 3
to use them instead of using the default
container all containers have a signal
that is emitted when the container has
to rearrange its children as you can see
here by selecting this horizontal box it
has the S children signal and you can
use this to implement your own custom
container by creating a script that and
hire it from the container but we are
not going to do this in this tutorial
here we have a different type of
container which is a margin container
the margin container keeps all of its
children inside a given margin that can
be configured in the inspector going
down to the inspector and open up the
custon constants you see that we have
them preconfigured to be 75 on each side
of this margin container we can change
this value and you notice that
everything inside is going to be
rearranged accordingly so if I increase
this value to to 120 for instance you
notice that the panel container gets
shifted to the left because we are
adding more margin to the right you
don't have to use all of these constants
you can use only the ones that you want
so if we deactivate some of
them everything gets rearranged
accordingly again because we're using a
margin container as a direct child of
this margin container we have a panel
container a panel container is a simple
container that just have a background on
it and this background is going to have
the same look as set it on the theme so
if you want to change the look of the
default container you can go to the
theme and create a new one and there
you'll be able to change the look of
this panel container and as a child of
it we have a dummy text which is just
there to Showcase how everything works
when we change the values at the margin
container here on the game scene we have
a GUI scene and here we have the most
complex scene of our game you notice
that all of this scene is pretty much
made by horizontal and vertical box
containers as well as some margin
containers the root node is a horizontal
box container that has the same size of
the screen and is anchored as a full rck
you can see this by pressing h on your
keyboard and you'll be able to see these
Green Dots to visualize where your
control is anchored to we will start off
by taking a look at this panel which is
a margin container that has 20 of margin
on each side of it this way we don't
have the N patch rack touching the edges
of our screen we then have a margin
container which is used to keep the
contents of it not touching the border
of the background that we are using for
this stats panel and again we are using
a vbox container to keep everything
arranged as a list and this is really
useful because here you can see that we
have a demo of a character select but if
we had a character that didn't have an
attack property or had another type of
property if we decide to remove the
attack for instance you notice that the
defense goes all the way to the top
again it gets rearranged by the vertical
box container and we don't have to do
anything and we don't have to worry
about it so if we wanted to add more
types of stats to our character or
remove some because the character is a
mage so it doesn't have an attack it has
a skill stats we wouldn't have to worry
about arranging everything and Mak it
making everything look pretty because
the vbox container is already taking
care of that for us if I open the
defense scene you notice that it is an
inhered scene and it inherits from the
attack scene and again we are pretty
much just using vertical and horizontal
box containers so you can really see how
powerful they are to create really good
looking UI elements and you can mix and
match them to get to your desired look
so for instance if I decide that I don't
want to use an icon anymore here I can
just expand this horizontal walk
container so as you can see it holds the
I icon and the label and if I remove the
icon again everything gets rearranged
accordingly because we are using
containers now back to the GUI
scene the second part of the UI that we
have here is the character selector and
this is just a vertical box container
that has an horizontal box container
that holds the two buttons that we need
to select our character and has our
character in the middle and right below
it we have the select button and
everything is arranged correctly because
of the vertical box container if I play
this scene you notice that everything
looks the way that it was here in the
inspector but if I decide that I don't
want this to be the way it is right now
I want to change the way something looks
and I take this next button right here
and I place it little bit to the top and
I decide to play the game again you can
see that it goes back to the correct
position so again the containers are
going to take control of your control
nodes and you have to make them look the
way you want them to look by using their
functionality you not be able to change
their position because they all get
rearranged when the game is played and
another thing that you should keep in
mind is the size flags of your
controls here you notice that this panel
container is taking all the space that
it can and that is because that's how it
was configured to to behave for for
instance if I go to the panel container
open the size flags and I remove the F
and I set it to
expand you notice that now it's only
taking the space that it needs for the
dummy text to appear the same applies to
the boxes demo that we had on the
beginning of this lecture they're all
taking as much space as they can because
the size flags are configured to do that
so that's why when I show this button
they get arranged correctly if I were to
for instance select all of
them and instead instead of using
Fu I decid to use
expand you notice that they're only
taking as much space as they need to and
again the same applies for this
horizontal box so I'm going to remove
the fu
and there you go I really hope that this
gave you a basic understanding of how
containers work on gdo if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
them on the comment section below and
also every feedback is appreciated you
can find this project on the GitHub link
that's going to be on the description of
this video as well as the svgs that were
used to create the UI for this tutorial
so thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you next time